je le disais avant la pause denis
gallant est devenu l'ultime chaîne garde
pour une meilleure moralité dans
l'octroi des contrats à montréal ce
nouveau poste découle vous souvenez
évidemment d'une promesse du maire denis
coderre lors de la dernière campagne
municipale j'ai rencontré m gallen et à
peu près une heure
voici ce que ça donne denis gallant
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur roy quand vous
regardez les télés dans notre salle des
nouvelles voyez la commission
charbonneau avez vous des regrets et
fois ce que vous êtes parti là avec
douleur avec difficulté quand même avec
un certain certains certes un
déchirement la commission charbonneau
j'y étais dès les premières heures
c'était même charbonneau m'appeler au
mois de novembre 2011 de qu'elle a reçu
son mandat j'ai toujours pensé d'avec là
jusqu'à la fin jusqu'à la fin du rapport
mais elle est arrivée cette belle
opportunité de créer le rôle
d'inspecteur général pour la première
fois au canada et je vous dirai malgré
une certaine déception bavoirs a été
jusqu'au bout de la commission je suis
très heureux aujourd'hui une nouvelle
fonction est est ce que vous êtes
convaincu que vous allez faire une
différence pour les montréalais
autrement dit dans cette grosse machine
qui la ville de montréal j'allais
pouvoir vous trouvez des contrats mal
données ou des choses malfatti s'ils ont
je suis confiant
la ville la ville donne la ville jusque
là ville d'abyei ces arrondissements
c'est paramunicipale ces terres assez
des millions et des millions et des
millions de contrôles d'argent public
on a vu il n'y a pas tellement longtemps
comme
il ya des gens 69 à la collusion
pourquoi les contrats d'avs est de
montréal a coûté beaucoup plus cher que
chez terra il ya eu l'effet du paquet eu
d'effet comme sur charbonneau mais je
pense qu'il faut qu'il y ait un effet
permanent puis le bureau de l'inspecteur
général c'est quelque chose qui existe
dans les grandes villes américaines est
ce que j'ai pu voir c'est que ça
fonctionne
les gens peut-être crois que j'allais
être seul dans un bureau tu sais pas du
tout le cas là c'est vraiment un bureau
qui sera en place
vous me disiez c'est une vingtaine de
personnels peu près je vous dirai a vu
neiger pas encore la fête encore tout le
tour de mes besoins que ça va se faire
de façon graduelle
mais si je veux une équipe qui est
multiple nager une équipe sur le terre
et je veux des juricomptables je veux
des gens qui connaissent les contrôles
des gens qui connaissent la ville
également et ses arrondissements donc
très vite on passe déjà là possiblement
une vingtaine de personnes est un petit
peu plus sur un budget de 5 millions ce
qui votre patron le conseil de ville
d'accord il exerça le maire il y aura
pas de contact il n'y aura pas de
demande particulière
vous êtes au service de tous les élus
montréal tout à fait c'est à dire que ma
nomination devra être entérinée par les
deux tiers du conseil municipal et si
jamais on veut me démettre de mes
fonctions avant l'échéance du 5 1 ça
prend également votre vieux routier du
conseil municipal vous l'avez dit c'est
une tâche qui est énorme parce qu'il y
avait quoi 5 milliards de budget à
montréal la police sait et c'est quoi
677 millions stm 400 millions le matin
quand vous commencez vous qui comme m
comment vous faites pour trouver parce
que ça on peut se perdre rapidement dans
tout ça je vous dirais il ya déjà on va
commencer déjà à chercher des places et
déjà des partenaires des comme le bureau
du vérificateur général qui peut nous
alimenter bureau du contrôleur général
qui peut alimenter de bureau de
l'inspecteur général mais également la
loi prévoit également toute la nation
excusez-moi l'angle des 6 2 way sur dow
avec toute une mécanique de protection
pour protéger ses dénonciateurs là les
gens pourront vous appelez un employé de
montréal que j'appelais dire et sans
qu'ils soient jamais
que son nom soit jamais révélé dans la
loi prévoit que je dois conserver son
anonymat et les montres la personne
qu'on sente parce que les identités
soient révélés et je peux également
donné cette information là au corps
policier et par rapport au vérificateur
général au contrôleur général
est-ce que c'est pas une couche de trop
vous êtes convaincu que c'est vraiment
utile
c'est très utile avec les pouvoirs qui
sont donnés par le projet de loi 73 à
dire c'est des pouvoirs que les autres
organismes n'ont pas saisi le service de
police de la ville demandant que ce soit
les thèmes que ce soit l'utac fait des
enquêtes criminelles donc avec un but
bien précis de monter une enquête pour
effectivement arrêts et éventuellement
les contrevenants il est des traduire
devant les tribunaux de juridiction
criminelle
le service de police n'a pas le pouvoir
de suspendre un contrôle le service de
police ou du rôle du contrôleur général
ne pas ok le pouvoir pour arrêter un
appel d'offres l'inspecteur général de
par ses pouvoirs dévolus par le projet
de loi 73 à ses pouvoirs lors vous
n'avez pas le pouvoir de contraindre
ceux dans votre esprit vous avez
suffisamment de pouvoir néanmoins c'est
ce que vous avez dit pourquoi pourquoi
parce que la loi prévoit que même eux
mêmes séries donc les fonctionnaires
sont liés doivent répondre à mes aux
questions du bureau de l'inspecteur
général doit fournir les renseignements
demandés par l'inspecteur général doit
également laissé accès aux locaux à
respecter en général même de prêter
assistance à l'inspecteur généralisation
personnel pour la foule par exemple d'un
ordinateur
en contrepartie si les gens refusent
il ya des infractions prévues au projet
de loi 113 qui sont des infractions
pénales qui est déjà un pot de grand
maman très bien donné gagnant dans un an
si on se revoit comment va mesurer le
travail que vous avez fait ce que toutes
les interventions j'allais faire seront
ultime en public
ces bus en toute transparence a dit que
la loi prévoit que je dois transmettre
au conseil municipal une fois lens c'est
un minimum
une fois là leur rapport de l'inspecteur
général
donc les dossiers qui vont avoir été
fait ça va être publié et ça va être les
montréalais vont pouvoir savoir ce que
leur inspecteur général a fait ci a par
contre des enquêtes à coup vous allez
comprendre que ses enquêteurs ont
privilégié et peut-être si un jour ça
aboutit elles vont être transmises au
public le gala il ya beaucoup de
montréalais qui vous souhaite bonne
chance
on se reparlera dans les prochains mois
merci beaucoup